Hey, Ray, you're what I would call a homosexual.
Mr. Misha, you shouldn't talk about these things too
openly; no matter how you touch on it, it'll only cause trouble, so you can
talk about it separately,
but as a close friend who wants to hear it,
I'm curious.  Maybe, but I guess that's the case with
me. I've
never been in love with a man before, so what's wrong with you, Claire? It's because
everyone
feels in danger. It's true that I
don't trust Ray based on his usual behavior, but Claire.  I
think that reaction is too biased just because it's Aisa.
For example, Claire-sama is a heterosexual Aisa. It's
natural that she likes sailors. Claire-sama who doesn't
let rain chicha in
doesn't want men to attack her.
What would you think if I told you that?I'm not that wise,
but what Claire-sama
did to Rei earlier is exactly what I meant.As
Mishi said, I
don't have lust for any person at any time.That's
heterosexual love.  It does
n't matter if you're deaf or gay. That's true. Gender has nothing to do with love. It just happens that the
person you fell in love with happens to be a woman. That's not true.
Gender does have something to do with it.
Yeah, when you fall in love, you change your
gender.  It may be true in theory that it doesn't matter,
but
I don't like men.It seems like there
are various prejudices.I
won't have a chance to find out, so I can't help it.All I can do is admire Claire
every day.  Claire, I'm happy,
so why don't we fall in love with each other?
Or rather, you're always like that, so I'm trying to
protect myself. I
completely agree with that.
That kind of
OG.